many things that evolutionary biology
cannot explain
so far might be explained by a host
pathogen koi value including aging so
hello and welcome to the cheeky Science
Show
but in this video I spoke with Peter
lipsky current postdoctoral fellow at
the University of California San
Francisco liske originally started his
career studying and Terry viruses and
since then he moved to Zurich in
Switzerland where he switched to his
focus on drosophila as a model organism
for Gene regulation and development now
he combines his interests industrophla
and Pharisees in understanding the
evolution of Adrian
um I firstly just wanted to start with
your Twitter bio where you describe your
interests as evolution of aging virology
and drosophila and so I just thought
maybe you can give some backstory to how
you got to the position where you're at
today and discuss some of your interests
uh
well there is not much of specific
good things to
say probably probably since young
scientists probably see us you can put
the running Title Here all the tricks
are made by professionals about the
major success do not try to repeat at
home so I have been changing my topic
several times and this is not what you
should do so but finally I ended up
where I am in the
I think I I think I found a cool story
on aging and I can use this my virology
and address of expertise to pursue this
puzzle so I started as a virologist then
accomplished some projects then decided
I will go to something completely
different
and then I decided I want to uh
connect both parts of expertise
virusesophila
and then I found a very peculiar
phenotypes that are not published yet
and that that led to the theory so that
of the that aging might be an adaptation
an Adaptive suicide like adaptive death
so and the the Aging part so far is
mainly theoretical like math
if you're
uh he described aging as a paradox so
why exactly is aging considered a
paradox
oh well evolutionary it's a paradox the
idea of evolution is replication and if
I die by age I cannot replicate anymore
so it definitely should be bad for my
fitness and if
if you look so the like archaic view on
Aging was that just animals in the wild
do not survive to the uh age where there
is an S and that's why aging is sort of
neutral
but then if you look carefully into
ecology we see that no like a line of
age of 14 has much better chance to die
earlier than the line of age of four and
lions can survive to the age of 14 in
the wild so aging is definitely not
neutral and this is paradoxical because
if Lions would live longer we would live
more progeny
exactly so I think that's that's like
clearly several different theories that
have been proposed to explain uh why
aging seems to have Arisen and one of
them actually you've already sort of
described is this extrinsic mortality or
I think it's the selection Shadow maybe
that's what you're describing but
um what are the other current theories
of like why we age and why do you think
that they have limitations
yeah so the major thing for now is this
antagonistic pleiotropy if this is like
a pay later hypothesis so like aging is
something like college loan then we are
so strong when we're young but then uh
we need to pay for it and if we wouldn't
pay in our old ages we wouldn't be as
fit in young years
so it's like uh
uh uh like a transaction delayed
but uh it's not clear what is the
mechanism and it's not clear what is the
currency
uh so the uh initially the concept was
that there are pleiotropic genes that
are good in young years and bad in Old
years and if we assume existence of such
genes then this model can work
because still the mortality is there and
uh much less and less animals are
surviving to the old ages so the
demographic pyramid is built like that
here are young animals here are old
Animals number of old animals is always
smaller so everything that improves
Fitness in young years should still
should be selected better
but all that requires genes with two
opposite functions
good and young years but in Old years
and how this can work is very difficult
to imagine because uh no you know the
unit of mutation is much smaller than a
gene it's a nucleotide and there is I
haven't found a single convincing
example of a gene that kind of evolution
cannot resolve
let's assume related species
squirrel right a rat leaves two years
squirrel lives 20 years so rat ages so
fast because there are some genes that
I'm missing from Square also this is a
completely different mechanism
or in spiritual Evolution somehow
managed to uncouple these connections so
these questions are unanswered so and if
you uh
challenge the people who are like uh
uh
followers of the antagonistic pleiotropy
idea they will uh either bring you uh
examples that you immediately can
destroy
with the
nature observation
observations or they uh refer to
experiments in experiments sometimes you
can see the uh phenotypes that are up
sort of predicted from antagonistic
pleiotropy but these observations are
not fully investigated and they can have
alternative explanations and our model
can produce this alternative
explanations which are to me are more
feasible
okay yeah so from my perhaps naive
understanding of antagonistic player
droopy is that it considers aging itself
to be a bad thing to happen but we can
explain that by saying that it was these
apparent genes that were beneficial when
younger and as a consequence agents like
the like the um unfortunate side effects
of selecting for these but apparent good
genes in the early years like
pre-reproductive
um age and so on the flip side there's
also theories that aging is actually
adaptive so
um what other theories besides the ones
that you've come up with
um seem to suggest that aging itself is
actually an Adaptive thing to happen
yeah so the
adaptive aging theories are also around
for a long time but most of them uh uh
like uh lacks strong no so I I don't
want to upset people who produce them
but I think they are still uh not very
convincing uh from the point of
evolutionary biology because they
require very stringent uh very stringent
assumptions so like they are so there is
an idea that the research release that
we die to give space to our approach to
our progeny or this is for acceleration
of evolution or it is uh for control of
population density that we avoid like
overpopulation and collapsing all these
require group selection in group
selection so I do not want to go in much
detail but it is considered a very uh
very infrequent in nature so like when
selection works not on an individual
Fitness interest but on the big group
like a group of non-related animals are
altruistic to each other and they are
selected as a wall
uh this is believed to be a very rare
rare because uh the egoists that is uh
evolving in such a altruistic group can
take over all the uh of the group this
time oh yes
okay I see so I think that's now nicely
leads us on to your Theory of Aging or
like why why aging seems to have Arisen
say this pathogen control strategy so
would you be able to elaborate on why
this idea came from and what exactly is
this Theory
no so
in brief so we do not use group
selection
and this is main advantage of our Theory
and what differs us from the uh previous
theory of adaptive aging so idea is that
uh pathogens infectious diseases are the
strongest selective factor in nature so
if you like uh look into the uh
uh evolutionary papers that work with
bacteria so often people use like five
percent Fitness ten percent fitness
meaning that bacteria which is
replicating five percent better than
other bacteria is getting benefits and
the five percent is uh like
by uh able to eat some some substrates
that other bacterias cannot so and these
five percent of fitness gain is
something but if we look in uh
epidemiological model where you let's
say we add a phage to this bacterial
culture the phage will kill like
99.99 of all bacteria and uh the uh
several bacteria which are resistant
will get like thousands of percent of
Fitness game
so and we do not need to wait while one
strain will over replicate the other
so it is just
pathogens are very strong selective
force and we can also see it from
genetics everything that is associated
with uh
immune system evolves much faster so
you can also Google Red Queen hypothesis
like to stand in the play there is a
constant co-evolution between hosts and
pathogens and to just be in the steady
state hosts still need to evolve its
immune system to adapt to evolving uh
pathogens uh well we we might not see
any phenotypic difference just pathogens
become stronger host immunity becomes
stronger
and even to like in Alice in Wonderland
by Lewis Carroll to stay in the place we
need to evolve so uh that's the uh uh
why we believe that
many things that evolutionary biology
cannot
explain
so far might be explained by a host
pathogen including aging so the basic
idea so if we have the uh if we have a
disease which doesn't kill like HIV for
example like in a mantis it doesn't kill
much so and but it sterilizes so monkeys
are less fetal they produce less progeny
then this
infected monkey is a rather problem for
its genes than a benefit
and because it doesn't replicate very
well but it can in fact its relatives
who are located around
and then the genes of this monkey want
to kill it just and because there there
are some uncertainties in pathogen
detection pathogen symbols very fast
they can avoid immune detection
of the host so host might want to kill
itself prophylactically even without
information about infection studies
and the uh why it wasn't discovered
before uh because there is a little
technical uh I think I I want to add
that because uh the fact that relatives
are interacting more often than not
non-relative and viscous population this
fact wasn't very well started in
epidemiological models
so this is a like a technical novelty
that we introduced uh contributed to
science
okay yeah so I think we'll come back to
the viscosity element but firstly just I
wanted to talk more about these
pathogens themselves as she mentioned
about
um them sterilizing the individual is
that like necessary for this um
hypothesis to be uh true or is it
possible that you could also in theory
pass on the Infectious Disease agent to
offspring and that could also have
negative consequences
it should decrease Fitness it can be
also that it may might kill with the
long uh long incubation and infection
period
like uh if there is a death
uh highly infectious disease
that is long and lethal in the end also
probably can select for uh for a shorter
lifespan now we I can tell our last news
so we believe that you know the
Tasmanian devil I I think I told you
before right we should elaborate to the
viewers but yeah so they foreign
idea is that there is there are a sort
of adaptive death in animals that is
called similar parity that's like
Salmons the fish goes up the river lay
eggs and die
very strange type of behavior and
actually in mammals it's not around
almost with the exception for one clay
or two plates of marsupial carnivores
didel feed and does
and in this marsupial carnivores similar
parity evolves several times like more
than five times
independently
it seems to be that there are different
mechanisms of this death
and uh
how the
mainstream evolutionary theory explains
that
it is it is not clear because in all the
other mammals it never happens only in
this plate but several times and we
believe that this is a response to very
specific diseases that have uh like uh
so our model predicts that it should
evolve in response to this a strong uh
strong virulence so they kill and uh
very fast transmission they spread very
well because uh
then so the the the selection selection
power should be gross to to this thing
to evolve and as you might know in
Tasmanian Devil which is also a member
of dazoorida at the biggest it's like a
small dog like marsupial living in
Tasmania
recently they acquired the transmissible
cancer
uh these are cancer cells that can
transform it can go from one host to
another by bites
and uh the uh it's speaking during the
breeding season because during breeding
season they fight a lot
and then uh if the animal acquired this
disease it will die before the next
breeding season
so and during this time it can still can
spread locally because they also bite
around carcasses sometimes
uh that they fight for food but uh
these infected animal doesn't have big
uh big replication uh
replication potential because it will be
probably die anyway
and removing these animals right after
the breeding season might be adapted we
already pitched it yesterday the uh our
letter went out in transa college
Evolution uh with this hypothesis and uh
and the Curious Thing is that this
transmissible cancer in Devils is now
represented by two independent lines one
emerged like 30 years ago and the second
emerged like 10 years ago or 15 years
ago and uh it is uh uh specifically
curious because uh you know there is
only one or two other uh transmissible
cancers known in mammals so like dog
transmissible cancer uh and it seemed to
be that these marsupials are
specifically susceptible for induction
of transmissible cancers
and then it would put the puzzle all
together so the uh
if marsupials are susceptible for the
induction of transmissible cancers then
they have
like a metastable metastable epidemics
they induce it they have this epidemics
of viral and transmissible disease that
kills most of the animals like it
happened uh Tasmanian Devil and disease
goes away or adapts becomes more benign
as we predict from The evolutionary
presetology and then
you cancer is induced again and again
this thing repeats and this can
put a constant selection selection
pressure to evolve similarity so this is
like still a hypothesis we are working
on modeling all that but
at least it is it is something that can
explain it it can produce a better
explanation than uh mainstream model
yeah and there's a really interesting
example and as you mentioned this is
only relatively recent these clothes and
so I mean clearly they were the the like
the ancestor before these clads
separated
also was aging so I guess from my
understanding you're saying that now we
have this additional observation of this
transmissible cancer this might further
select for
like increased summer parity or maybe I
just misunderstood oh yeah the the
Devils now are not similar battles and
maybe in Devils uh similarity might not
evolve because of the population
structure so that's what we are now
studying but uh they just uh just I
exposed to these cancers they do a huge
population uh ups and downs because of
this and others that evolve similarities
they they can uh control cancers with
just killing all the uh males or in some
species both genders are die
a way that you can actually test the
model that you've proposed and like um
well sort of so the prediction from here
is to find uh transmissible cancers in
other marsupers
okay okay yeah so
um besides looking at the transversible
cancers in terms of like other lines of
evidence that supports your theory
you've mentioned already how
um like viruses Etc have a strong
selection pressure because of like the
Red Queen hypothesis
um but what is the strongest evidence to
actually support uh this hypothesis that
you're presenting
what is the strongest evidence uh well I
think it's a matter of taste so
uh we have classified our like all the
observations and we think that our model
can produce uh like a better Stitch to
the reality than the classical model so
for example uh
thoughts and bats everything but flies
lives longer than terrestrial forms and
it is not about being bird because the
non-flying rated Birds they don't have
extremely long lifespan for their Mass
so it's about flight not about
something else why do the typically
people say okay this is because they are
better protected because they fly and
the cat cannot catch the sparrow but if
you look in ecologic data and look for
animal mortality of sparrows you find
it's very very high so it's like 60 70
per year
uh and the sparrow can live 20 years
which is completely uh kind of off for
terrestrial animal and this is not clear
why so the the uh correlation between
longevity and flight doesn't have uh uh
doesn't have explanation in classic
Theory so but we propose that it is
because of this viscosity so for our
model it's necessary that relatives are
interacting more than non-relatives
to infect them uh
and if the population is well mixed so
that uh interactions are more
promiscuous than a long life
should evolve and it is known that this
person in Birds is like about 10 times
bigger than in uh terrestrial animals of
their sizes
yeah I I I I probably need to specify
that this uh this interaction between
relatives is needed to
run kin selection so because if I will
kill myself to save everyone in the
audience my genes will not proper from
that from that so I need to sacrifice to
help my own progeny and only that will
promote my the evolution of my genes
okay so let's just sort of summarize
flights
um organisms that can fly have like a
lower no
lower viscosities they're mixing about a
bit more and so there's therefore a
weaker selection for aging because
they're less likely to pass on
um any infectious agents
okay so then what does that tell us
about
um so that's like flight versus
terrestrial but what about I guess like
early organisms well like more um sea
based
um so
um water uh like aquatic organisms
versus terrestrial if we think back to
like when did aging first arise or like
um could it have Arisen multiple times
what can we learn about
um like using your model what could we
learn about Blended aging first like a
full adaptively does that make sense
I don't know well I'm not a big expert
in made in life forms but you probably
move the discussion towards towards
organs that do not age right like hydras
or planaria is it your uh we can head
that direction sure yeah
it works so I uh the uh
We've wrote in our review that they
probably cannot disc mechanistically uh
discriminate between reproduction and
regeneration
and if you cannot disconnect these two
things then you have to stand the high
infection portal on the other hand also
hydras which are non-aging they can
switch to the Aging form
and uh I I'm not a huge expert but I
think they do it in response to stress
and it might be that uh just in if they
are infected they rely on the pathogen
detection and switch to an aging form to
clear the trouble
and then they go to the non-aging again
so uh but
this is something that I need to read
more about
okay yeah
so generally yeah generally what uh
swims in the ocean
behaves a little bit different because
pathogens can also diffuse across a
bigger distances than also vertical
transmission is uh low I believe is
lower in the life forms that do not are
not
vibe apparels
so the uh the rules there are a little
bit different
okay yeah I see all right wait um the
other thing that made me think of though
are like plants and obviously they're
um they're fixed I mean they'll see me
but they can't
um they're not like animals that move
about and so there are many like very
long-lived species of trees
um and like how does like um they also
get infected by different agents does
that model of Aging in plant-based
organisms fit in with your model as well
thinking very superficially about that
so uh one need to model that accurately
and I'm afraid I cannot answer that in
principle yes it it can be true so why
why trees are living so long of course
to to grow grow large you must live long
so to use the benefits of the size uh uh
you need time and
these benefits of the size can a beast
bigger than the uh uh than the penalty
positive by pathogens
right so there is always trade-off so
the the the the the the the the virus
pathogens are all surrounded plants they
are transmitted by insects in principle
it also can work
if you think about uh like uh plants
that drop leaves and Evergreen plants uh
then you might find that Evergreen
plants typically uh have some uh better
protection against insects than others
but
I'm not sure this is a strong uh
argument so far
okay yeah so somewhat compelling I would
say though but I think one of the things
that I find interesting is
um just lastly considering the agent
could be adaptive I'm in this situation
and then what it tells us about
um like how many times aging might have
evolved whether there was one
um like Universal ancestor that got
infected and like whether that was like
clear evolution of the origin of like
virus or whatever this first infectious
agent was and aging itself or whether
you've even like thoughts that far back
no so we believe aging is part of the
immune system it's not not a virus thing
so it's a host protection that benefits
the kin and not the individual itself
just to make sure we're on the same page
so uh I uh the answer to your question
is I don't know so I think the what we
see in nature uh tells us that aging is
quite conserved
so I think it's reasonable to
hypothesize that it was the
single event but the problem is that
still aging is not defined
and uh
we know that something bad happens with
age but the clear scientific definition
is still missing
and with this uh
this input it's very difficult to speak
about Evolution it seems to be that
conserved genes are involved
okay ask
it on from now it's obviously there's
been a like a while for studies I've
investigated like different like aspects
of Aging senescent cells
um proteostasis autophagy
um nutrient sensing like how does this
Theory fit into the current observations
made in the so-called different
Hallmarks of Aging
uh which observations are you speaking
about so these
so many of them so like how does um the
observations that we've observed to
extends lifespan and different organisms
in the lab fit in with this hypothesis
so
I don't think that there is some
contradiction to whatever experimental
data we have served
uh so the uh the problem with Hallmarks
of Aging is that it is not clear what is
the uh reason and what is consequence
right so if uh
uh so the
uh General uh uh again coming back that
aging is not defined it is a problem
because if you don't know what it is we
cannot figure out what is important
right so if we like people are uh
getting myopic with age this is a
favorite bloodish of argument and so if
you prescribe them glasses we can uh
increase their uh uh because myopic
people are hit by cars let's say so if
you prescribe glasses then we increase
survival we increase life quality but we
don't cure aging and same can be true on
biochemical level the uh targeted
mitochondria get a little bit better
result but it it might be secondary
effect
and uh
the uh
uh
problem with the uh this Hallmarks is
that it is not a structured like
sequence of
events it's a number of observations
they do not contradict uh
our model anyhow
okay so how do you then think that
having this model in place will help us
like as researchers better design
experiments to find out what aging is
no so we believe that as I told that
aging is part of the immune system and
then it gives some handles because some
approaches gives predictions for example
it's known that uh
so it's known that the
uh
chronic infection can accelerate aging
people who live with HIV even if they're
on therapists they are on average five
years older according to a methylation
markers
so this is what is predicted by our
model
so the uh
uh
we believe that immune system is
something that should orchestrate the
whole process
and generally the uh
generally the idea that aging is
adaptive
is a big deal because no let's say
as an example the these para biosis
experiments right so the two mice one
old mice or one young mice got connected
the old mice gets younger the uh young
mice gets older so it has been done like
uh
20 years ago and uh for a long time
people were trying to identify factors
from young blood that can make uh old
old mice younger
but like in 2019 I believe uh Convoy
Labs Conboy slab they published it just
replacing plasma with
uh with albumin of course almost as good
as young plasma so it's not meaning that
aging is not a loss of function not
something is missing from there or
ordering it's gain of function something
emerges in the old organism
and I think if the uh idea that aging
can be adaptive would come before then
it would be less time between these two
experiments than 15 years
so but
this uh focus on Aging as a stochastic
entropic uh generally detrimental effect
moved Focus to uh I think in the wrong
direction
okay so obviously the immune system is
incredibly like complex
um so even one humans but following many
species but
um how exactly do you think that we can
now use this more focus on the immune
system to understand ways to actually
intervene in the aging process I mean
you just mentioned the example of blood
dilution but
like what exactly
um does that tell us about how to Target
the immune system given that obviously
it has benefits in terms of preventing
us from diseases
um but uh yeah
yeah so good question so we are working
on that and we are like in a not in a
advanced stage of it but we also believe
that sellers in essence is a immune
Thing by uh by evolutionary design so
because as you might know Sellers and
Essence has been proposed to be
anti-cancer uh think that if the cell
undergoes the neoplastic transformation
it activates a pathway and
gets into this senescence State and then
it's cleared by immune system
the question is why it's so complex why
don't go into apoptosis
and but
then when people studied in more detail
they found that presence of this
National cells is very cancer promoting
so the everything uh like in the I think
initial transformation and androgenesis
metastasis proliferation everything
goes worse for a patient and better for
cancer
so and it is not clear what force the
national cell sign needed and we believe
this is an antiviral uh story that
infected cell somehow uh uh
activates the pathway and uh
uh signal the immune system and then uh
this antiviral story became uh involved
in adaptive dying
and we believe that virus if it is
antiviral then viruses must have
interactors
that can affect the uh
uh that can affect affect some essence
and that's what we are doing now because
of my virology background we are trying
to find uh interactions between viruses
and senescence but uh also very
importantly
our model proposes a huge uh huge
support for Synergy therapies because as
you might also know uh many evolutionary
biologists think that if senescent cells
are there they are good for something
and the removing them might be either
detrimental or not very helpful
so our model suggests that they are here
just to kill us and synolytics must work
mm-hmm interesting because I think I
think yeah I remember you mentioned
senescence and when I met you almost a
month ago now um at the other conference
and I believe you also have done some
preliminary work with p53 which is
obviously kind of well my my interest
but um and important in terms of
understanding this decision between cell
deaf and entering senescence so um if
you're willing to would you be able to
remind you what it was you you've done
so far with looking at p53 in terms of
this response not well I think for a
broader audiences might be a little bit
premature because we don't have
mechanistic data so far we just have
phenotypes but I want to share that uh
you know p53 is a key protein for solar
semesters it has been discovered like
correct me if I'm wrong six times uh by
six independent labs and five of them
were biologists
so the because it was found as an
interactor with the big T antigen of
sv40 and some groups identified it first
as a viral protein because it
accumulates in the nuclei of the
infected cells so uh and a big DT
antigen is inactivating p53 so for sure
there is some interaction so what we we
see we see in drozophila we see that it
seems to be that p53 somehow is involved
in detection of The Chronic infection
and shortening the lifespan in response
to Chronic infection but this result
should be still considered as
preliminary
of course yeah but that's
definitely and and like the association
is not the right word but obviously in
terms of defining what a senescent cell
is is something that's like with aging
being able to Define what is aging
within this in essence field it's still
not clear what exactly is a senescent
cell given a sort of heterogeneity but I
suppose it also links in with the fact
that p53 itself isn't universally found
in all organisms maybe there's like
proteins that are very similar to it but
it does suggest that
um again that there's an element of
universality to this mechanism but and
different species that's going to be
slightly different mechanisms at play
yes I believe that p53 is DNA damage
response first of all right and I I uh
correct me I'm wrong I think in the
forms we don't have much of cellular
senescence so far right so solution
Essence I I don't think this is a
universal uh uh Universal mechanism
so uh
yeah but
I think the primary roles of p53 is
response to as uh DNA damage
so I was kind of exactly my my point is
that
um senescence might explain the aging
process in humans but for other
organisms where we see aging that still
fits your hypothesis but the mechanism
is going to be different yeah mechanisms
can be different because the Mac the
hypothesis proposes the Adaptive death
is good in epidemiological models but
the mechanism of this death can be very
different so the like in this case of
similar parity uh salmon it's not aging
at all it's like cortisol were shock and
a response to it so the
there can be a huge variation of ways to
die
so
um the size of what you're currently
working on like what are the other sort
of potential limitations of your own
model
um to be like your own sort of critic
uh
no well
so it is still much better than anything
else so but as you might know in science
we are never in the end points so we are
approaching the truth as we think but we
never uh
we never got
got to it finally so there uh
there are so the I asked many people to
find holes in my model
uh because it also I want to know it
first so what they found is uh like that
we can model very well how uh in
population of short-lived animals how
the if the long leaf mutant emerges how
it get
destroyed eliminated how the uh uh uh
limited lifespan can be preserved but
what if uh evolving a short life
starting from a long leaf population
so this we didn't modeled very
accurately I think we still can but uh
on the other hand uh there is a thing
called corpse rule that that in at least
in mammals Evolution typically goes from
small or smaller life forms to bigger
life forms so the small animals evolve
big and then get extinct and uh since uh
lifespan is correlating with the size
so it's expected that it always
increasing in evolution
and evolution back is not a very
frequent event
so this this is a small uh
small disadvantage
yeah there's no of course there are
there are like uh quantitative
arguments okay you say pathogens impose
a huge selection pressure and that can
explain aging but can you measure this
selection pressure
so we cannot yet so but the same
arguments can be uh can be
added to any other model of like uh
aging like if you say pleiotropic genes
Evolution cannot disentangle uh
beneficial and experimental traits how
strong this connection is
um ask a point
um so like the thing about Evolution
that I think I mean at least I tend to
forget about it is the fact that it's
still happening today like it's a
continuous uh process like um even as
the human species were still somewhat
well evolving albeit maybe different to
uh different rates to before but given
the model that you've now got in place
how do you like if you could predict
like hundreds years or like looking into
the future how do you think that
um of like rolling the the planets it's
going to influence the rate of Aging in
other species going forwards
no so uh hundreds of years is nothing of
course hundreds of millions is something
so but the uh for humans I believe that
we are involved evolving towards the
extension of the lifespan because we
already resolved uh most of the pathogen
problems just with the sanitation
uh and now vaccination and drugs uh so
the uh I I I think in couple of millions
of years we will get much longer life
spans
awesome and so um to kind of go back to
a point that you made at the start which
is that you've obviously been exposed to
many different areas not just the
biology but obviously maths and um your
previous research before now I just
curious to know
um because I always like to ask this
question like what sort of
um interesting books have you read or
things that really sort of um helped you
to sort of create this interesting
thought process or let's say basically
just any sort of book recommendations
the books
yeah
uh no I think I will be not very
original uh
um I must be but I can't so the uh no I
I read this like Watson the like
molecular biology of Gene very very dry
and the uh yeah the Dawkins
buttons
at the selfish Gene I guess oh yes yes
there are still I think they steal the
problem of sex is not resolved uh he is
claiming he did it but I don't think it
is resolved and it also might be
connected to to infections
okay
so um
diamonds and like the longevity aging
space at the moment
um in general and there's like things
like cellular reprogramming that seem
quite exciting I mean are there any
things are there any things besides
focus on focusing on the immune system
that you think is going to be quite
interesting
um in the next few years
oh
no well things are changing so fast
uh no generally there is a lot of Works
going on I'm a little bit concerned that
uh you know like as a virologist coming
to a different field I'm a little bit
surprised that uh like uh
people consider the observational
uh uh observational definitions
sufficient it's like if we would like to
cure covet
and we would say we see that there is
high temperature we see cough we see
warm it we see whatever
and we want to classify all these
symptoms and to invent the pill against
each of them and then we will cure covet
and we don't need to study virus because
uh because who cares about virus
important thing is damage that the virus
does to the human body
so I think in case of viruses it didn't
it definitely didn't fly
so in aging field instead of
microbiology or biology we have
evolutionary biology
and
it is still somehow I think underscored
so people think that the big data set
multi-omics they will like
map every protein in the human body and
understand everything
uh
so it still might it's uh
still like the Monte Carlo method of
looking for things like searching a
little bit here a little bit here it
might get us to some therapy
but I think chances are low
so I think we historically science work
like we asked simple questions we answer
simple questions we ask complex
questions
uh also in medicine you first get to
diagnosis then you think about treatment
and here I think this principle is
somehow eroded
nevertheless
nevertheless even with the uh like
uh without a solid solid trajectory we
can get to nice treatments
I'm not sure they will be a final
Solutions but yeah they might help
well yeah I'm glad I've been able to
give you this platform to speak about
your hypothesis because
um I mean I think I was lucky that Lisa
my in degree I had some sort of
um lecture series on inflationary
biology I would have to say that it was
my weaker points compared to
biochemistry but I agree that it's
definitely important to always be aware
um of the
um well the bigger picture as opposed to
just hyper focusing on what genes are
for as you say the observational
approach so do you have any other like
Words of Wisdom or like lots of advice
for current students or just anyone
listening uh that you would like to
share before you wrap up
uh no well uh my career is not ex the
best example too
trying to try to repeat so probably I um
this might be not very helpful
so the doctor cure yourself first but uh
yeah and I think
yeah now Academia is super competitive
and you need to think about the every
step you don't want to make uh like ah I
will make this decision and a couple
years later I will look uh what what
happens
so you you need to plan very in advance
and chat to people around specifically
when you choose a lab you need to uh
like the first things you need to do is
to look what happened with people who
left this lab recently
so the
uh of course it's a super exciting time
to be in science but it's very hard time
to be a scientist now
so but of course excitement uh
excitement overweight all the other
things
that's true
well I'm glad that yeah we've entered on
a high point
um it's been great talking to you and
for my viewers who wants to follow your
research I can put your Twitter in the
description but if there is there
anywhere else where I can send my
viewers
okay good
thank you sorry I was speaking so slowly
today I think I uh yeah and I think my
accent got even worse
seemed seemingly impossible but it's
good anyway
oh yeah thank you again for coming on it
was a really interesting and like
thought-provaking discussion so I'm
looking forward to yeah see some of your
more um more of your findings as you are
able to sort of provide more evidence to
support this hypothesis yes yes working
on this
what 24 7. exactly nice okay ciao so I
hope you've learned something in this
video thank you to my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening